me and my wife my wife gabrielle um
union we are we are proud when i say
proud we are proud parents um of a child
in the lgbtq plus community and we're
proud allies as well
[Applause]
yes ziya wade has two incredibly
supportive parents in her life dad nba
legend dwyane wade and stepmom gabrielle
union dwayne recently shared advice for
parents with trans children telling
variety doing what you're supposed to do
as a parent is to make sure that you sit
back and you see what it is in life that
they want to do and you try to go there
with them and try to help mold them into
what it is they want to be and who they
want to be we are just doing our job as
parents now ziya was recently honored
for being a trailblazer by logo for its
annual logo 30 series there are
genuinely people out there who think
that you're a kid this is a phase or you
don't actually know what you're talking
about i know that i'm trans
late last year the iconic jamie lee
curtis spoke in length about her
daughter ruby coming out as trans
telling people magazine i'm a grateful
student it's learning new terminology
and words jamie lee added you slow your
speech down a little you become a little
more mindful about what you're saying
how you're saying it you still mess up
i've messed up today twice we're human
and in may of this year jamie lee
officiated daughter ruby's cosplay
themed wedding look at how fun that was
now we all know busy phillips is a very
funny woman but she gets serious about
supporting her own queer non-binary
child birdie and spoke to other parents
with an instagram post that read quick
what do you call a parent who is
supportive of who their kid is a parent
that's all show up be supportive amplify
be loud because it might be your kid
someday but even if it's not what would
it say about you if you only care about
kids like your own the pronoun thing was
tricky and i think that the moment of
growth for me was was the self-education
like i gotta figure this out on my own
and i have to do research and i have to
read books and take in
what it means and also challenge myself
and my own ideas
about what gender is
now we all know cher is a queer icon but
she's also a supportive mother to her
trans son chaz
in 2020 cher opened up to cnn about
chaz's transition saying it wasn't easy
like i remember calling and the old
message the old chaz message was on the
phone and that was very difficult but
then you have one child but you don't
really lose them they are just in a
different shape and just like that star
cynthia nixon has always been someone to
show her own pride and back in 2018 she
shared her pride for her trans son seth
the very private charlize theron told
daily mail that her eldest child jackson
is trans and speaking about her
parenting said my job as a parent is to
celebrate them and to love them and to
make sure that they have everything they
need in order to be what they want to be
love that charlize
hey thanks for watching et canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out these videos